hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the joy of creation
this time we know and know foxy no get
out of here we've had enough of you foxy
we've got chica involved so welcome to
the party chica and I actually tried to
record this a little bit ago but
unfortunately chica my dog was in the
room and every time I said the word
chica she came running over and
interrupted my recording so she's down
in her playpen right now so let's get
started hi chica how are you doing
welcome to the party now the whole gangs
here and yes I have seen the new sister
location trailer it looks very good and
first of all [ __ ] that Dancy pants
character the one the ballet dancer you
know that's all those I mean I know
baby's doing fine collect ten drawings
within three minutes but if you haven't
seen the trailer go see it definitely
it's it's worth watching what them but
what what the hell white
I can only move the mouse when I'm know
for some reason I can only I can only
move it when I'm holding it down so
collect ten drawings within three
minutes
hmm where where and why where and why
okay let's see chica okay
I don't understand the mechanics in you
all right light it Road that makes me
feel nice and safe so how did chica come
running up and killing me how's that
happened
all right all Oh what the hell happened
what the hell was it because I was
looking at her oh man Oh baby oh man
okay
so don't look at her is the secret of
success here also I guess don't stand
still because that seemed to be in what
killed me before man this is definitely
if the other games didn't give me a
Slenderman vibe this one's definitely
popping it up considering I'm walking
through the woods literally collecting
notes off of trees if there's a big red
silo dildo in the distance I'm gonna be
very upset yeah
where she at oh boy this is uh this is a
this is a different experience huh
because I could try running that'd be
nice huh
I've got a law it's why I keep better
reach find me he's gonna buy me why what
did I do
I did I try to live a good life I try to
be friendly wow that that branch is just
doing the Wibbly dance okay so I don't
know I don't know I don't know what she
wants from me I don't know how to beat
this oh man oh man
death is gonna lurk
see the thing is okay sorry it's okay
it's only death that comes due to
constraints that I can't seem to control
and events there beyond my power to
wield what the [ __ ] is going huh huh
we try walking no flashlights how about
that maybe that will help what the [ __ ]
do I do I don't have a goddamn clue of
what I am supposed to do I don't know
how to beat this I have a funny feeling
that when chica comes a-runnin
there ain't nothing to be done I'm just
gonna I'm gonna tuck my head between my
knees and kiss my ass good-bye oh man
maybe if I compliment her on her style
her impeccable styles you'll leave me
alone
oh budget beginning to think that I got
a pranked version and it's literally
just uncontrollable death at random
intervals and there's not a damn thing I
can do
oh boy hey does it want me to like take
my time ah hello why did why did she
stop why'd she stop what what made her
stop I don't know that was that was
different though at least something
happened okay
I looked at her and she went away but
then I stared too long maybe
Oh
oh [ __ ]
okay
okay oh okay okay man that'd be [ __ ]
impossible how are you supposed to do
that especially considering you spawn at
random points around the map I mean not
random but like a few established points
how am I supposed to get my pairings man
I don't get it maybe I am supposed to
turn it off and then walk away I don't
know she's behind me
whoa whoa hey
oh I don't get it man she like pause for
a second but just a second
and if you do too long she hates your
guts
oh man I'll give it one more try but I
don't know man man this is rough whoa
[ __ ] what didn't I know you were there I
didn't know maybe she really did I have
a funny feeling she does not like the
flashlight is my main guess that's why
there are actual points of illumination
around the map with the lampposts those
are like giving you reference to where
you are and giving a little bit of light
cuz my instinct is she doesn't know
where I am
right away cuz otherwise she'd be making
a beeline for me so she kind of wanders
around and then stumbles across me and
then closes in for the kill
once she spots me cuz after a while she
doesn't really
oh [ __ ] well [ __ ] that idea
sounds like runnin either she doesn't
like runnin you don't like you look at
her you only like you try hey did I like
your ridin [ __ ] what a needy girl what a
needy needy needy chicas Joanie oh [ __ ]
okay I can't I can't do it I I don't
know I don't know I don't know maybe
you're supposed to like line-of-site her
with a tree that's the only other thing
I could possibly think of
like maybe [ __ ] I've reached the edge of
the map without finding another goddamn
page oh boy
there's one more good oh [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
back back back back back back
ok I can't do it is for more intrepid
souls than I this is for more persistent
douchebags than I am and I'm a pretty
persistent douchebag so let's just say
goodbye by running in a circle really
quickly okay so I have a theory about
chica this is what I think her behavior
is you can get away from her in the dark
she's very light based he only seems to
run up to me when I'm near sources of
light so if I say for example I'm
running around in the dark she's not
gonna bother me cuz she doesn't know
where I am but she can hear you you
still can't stare at her that's a
number-one rule you cannot stare at the
chica number one first and foremost
can't do it but the only problem is the
only way to get her to stop from killing
you if she's on your tail is to glance
at her so it's like this weird catch-22
system where you can't look at her but
there's also no gauge to know how soon
she is until you've had she's had enough
of you glaring at her so right here see
she's right there
by
if I say
Yesi I can get away from a little bit
not a hundred percent but you can get
away from her
never mind very broken
whoa [ __ ] didn't matter
[ __ ] I don't know I have no idea
theory broken it didn't work so I am
done I can't do it I if I had hours and
hours and hours then maybe maybe I could
do it but I don't have hours and hours
and hours I just have the time that I
have now so I will leave it up to you
guys to figure out the best way to beat
this if you can let me know cuz holy
[ __ ] this is difficult so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know if you beat it down in the comments
below and get me strategies for how to
do it for myself because the developer
did say that if you beat all of them you
get a little Easter Egger surprise a
secret or something like that so thank
you again and as always I will see you
in the next video thanks for watching
the series because it's going to get
loud crude pensively rude my head is
tickly I can't go
I think I love it